welcome back to the david pakman show i
am jesse dollamore out of work stunt
double for jim gaffigan
so yesterday something happened that
we've been waiting for for many years
and that is an infrastructure built to
pass during the trump administration it
seemed like infrastructure week was
every week
in perpetuity
materializing to nothing
and we passed less than we wanted less
than we need
certainly less than we deserve
but better than nothing
reading from this new york times article
entitled senate passes one trillion
dollar infrastructure bill handing biden
a bipartisan win
the approval came after months of
negotiations and despite deficit
concerns reflecting an appetite in both
parties for a long awaited spending
package
so the vote ended up being 69 to 30
which
is telling that they were able to get
nearly 20 republicans on board
even mitch mcconnell
in fact
the senate gave overwhelming bipartisan
approval on tuesday to a one trillion
dollar infrastructure bill to rebuild
the nation's deteriorating roads and
bridges and fund new climate resilience
and broadband initiatives delivering a
key component of president biden's
agenda the vote 69 to 30 was uncommonly
bipartisan
the yes votes included senator mitch
mcconnell of kentucky the republican
leader and 18 others from his party who
shrugged off increasingly shrill efforts
by former president
donald
j trump
to derail it
is the last part of that sentence
because that is it was indeed
the
uh the the mo has been the mo of trump
and the republicans for a long time
i am still weary
of what is happening
wary excuse me of what's happening here
what is to take place what's the uh
what machiavellian motivations do they
have
for overwhelmingly or for republicans
it's overwhelming support of this bill
the historic investment in
infrastructure is what i believe you the
american people want what you've been
asking for for a long long time mr biden
said from the white house as he thanked
republicans for showing a lot of courage
because in today's day and age
it is courage
to support an infrastructure bill that
is desperately needed as our bridges and
our tunnels and our roadways and our
infrastructure
is literally crumbling
mr mcconnell who publicly declared that
his priority was stopping the biden
agenda said in a statement that quote i
was proud to support today's historic
bipartisan infrastructure deal and prove
that both sides of the political aisle
can still come together around common
sense
solutions
if it were coming from anybody other
than mitch mcconnell i might believe it
the measure faces a potentially rocky
and time-consuming path in the house
where speaker nancy pelosi and a
majority of the nearly 100-member
progressive caucus
had said they will not vote on it unless
the senate passes a separate even more
ambitious 3.5 trillion dollar social
policy bill this fall
that could put the infrastructure bill
on hold for weeks if not months
and the the the method by which they
intend to press the senate to pass that
3.5 trillion dollar um
appropriation is through reconciliation
where they won't need they could bypass
the filibuster they could bypass
republican obstructionism
here is a little larger context a little
longer context of what joe biden said
in his speech first of all
i want to thank a group of senators
democrats and republicans
for doing what they told me they would
do
the death of this legislation was mildly
premature as reported
they said they're willing to work in a
bipartisan manner
and i want to thank them for keeping
their word that's just what they did
after years and years of infrastructure
week
we're on the cusp of an infrastructure
decade
that i truly believe will transform
america so it was a good day for the
country certainly a good day uh from an
agenda agenda standpoint for president
biden
there was another side though
that is the side of mike lee republican
from uh utah he is ted cruz without a
beard
not quite as salacious he's a little bit
more milk toast
but certainly an obstructionist
certainly someone who is whose agenda is
marked by his ability to
not vote for things that's his that's
his uh his pride and glory
is his ability to
not vote
here's mike lee people are still
digesting it
members of the senate are still
digesting it
look
we're in a period of great inflation
brought on by a period of almost
unfettered unrestrained federal spending
it bears no connection it seems to the
laws of mathematics or to the amount of
money that were brought in
this bill would spend
a staggering 1.2 trillion dollars it
would be yet another inflation bomb in
an economy that's already been carpet
bombed by other inflation bombs
i i grasped the fact that it's difficult
to put together a bipartisan package i
have nothing but respect for each of our
colleagues who were part of this effort
i also am willing to acknowledge that
the bill does a lot of good things and
would help a lot of deserving
beneficiaries there are a lot of people
who would benefit in a lot of ways from
it but there is a huge problem with it
it is not paid for the reason that we
know that that's a problem that it's not
paid for is that the one consistent
refrain that you hear from its sponsors
other than the fact that it's bipartisan
which which we know and which we respect
is the fact that it's paid for they'll
say over and over again that this bill
is paid for but when you look at the
pays the pay fors they don't add up
when you have pay fors that don't
actually pay you're just going to add to
the debt and deficit and this isn't a
good time
to be doing that it never ceases to
amaze me and never will cease to amaze
me these republicans who
who pride themselves now on on how is
this going to be paid for how are we
ever gonna pay for this we're saddling
our children with debt
as though this is a household and debt
means the same thing as you
owning a car and having credit card debt
it is not the same thing
but two
where was mike lee during the donald
trump administration that was running up
one and one and a half trillion dollar
deficits
while things were good economically in
the country
were you
mike lee
where were you
it just rings hollow
now listen i would uh i would be lying
if i didn't say that i'm a little
nervous about the aggressiveness of the
progressives
in congress the squad who i am
almost universally a fan of
but if if they push this too far and we
get nothing and they give the
republicans an excuse
to back out and not vote
for for whatever conference agreement
they come to on a bill
then we've lost
then we get nothing we don't even get
the one or 1.2 trillion
we get zero and we're back to square one
with the um
infrastructure week week after week kind
of a situation it's not good
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping